hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 5
video we got to meet Mockingbird for the
first time which was totally awesome
this guy's dad had a big WTF and Marvel
dropped a giant age of Ultron bomb next
week the big news is they're going to be
posting the first official Avengers 2
trailer during agents of shield during
the episode I already Z to break down
with a Comic Con trailer I'll add a link
in the description but they're basically
going to be posting new footage like the
new trailer will be all of new stuff
just because that's such a huge deal
that'll be the first video that I post
Tuesday night I'll post that before I
post the flash so be sure to subscribe
to get that I'll explain what's gonna be
going on in that trailer like what we're
gonna be seeing at the end of this video
but careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet so
starting with top five moments number
five Hydra is trying to weaponize the
Oppel esc' that group at the beginning
that they were testing it on where
people with ties to shield they use
cells from that woman in the cafe to try
and reverse engineer the effects the
interesting thing about that is there
really aren't that many people that have
actually touched the obelisk
so whenever Kraken was talking about
tissue cells he was talking about her
and before all that went down I
feel like he was gonna put Simmons on
that work like she was gonna be working
on Ava's research it was actually a
really cool Simmons hell cow Easter Egg
so when they were talking about milk
from the hell cow that's a character
named Bessie from the comics she
appeared in giant-sized Man Thing issue
number 5 so the story goes that she was
a regular cow dracula drank her blood
she died her farmer buried her then
three days later she roses a vampire cow
so now she's like a vampire cow with
humanoid qualities she had a crossover
with Howard the Duck so you could also
view it as like a Howard the Duck Easter
Egg number four Reina is in trouble I
feel kind of bad for a character but
it's like a classic mystique situation
where the evil temptress becomes
sympathetic because she gets mistreated
by the heroes who think that she's an
enemy and she gets mistreated by her own
allies the other villains so I feel like
we're headed for like a mystique magneto
situation like they're gonna set rain up
as a double agent inside Hydra
especially now that Skye's dad is
working with them it seems like what she
wants is just the evolution of the human
race like the natural progression of
things and as we saw at the end Kraken
and Skye's father really only care about
themselves even though both their goals
are a little bit different tiny violins
of course she's verified scumbag so of
course she's gonna burn Team Coulson at
the end think about it this way as like
the mystique of the series she's just
gonna hop around the chessboard between
the heroes and the villains and try and
walk away at the end I don't think of
her as an agent of chaos but she is a
bit of a low-key right now just hopping
back and forth between good and evil we
did get a little teaser of her backstory
too so apparently this guy's father did
something to her it sounds like it was
way more than just give her a place to
live and food to eat like he helped her
obtain some skills it seems like she has
low-level passive mutant abilities and
she's just tried to unlock her true
nature which screams Inhumans I don't
know that that's where the series is
going necessarily but it just feels like
everything she's been talking about for
the past two seasons so far has screamed
Inhumans think about it this way though
the obelisk is an alien device so it
could be what Marvel is using to
represent the Terrigen crystals and if
that's the case the map that everyone
keeps talking about could be a map to
Attilan the city of the Inhumans number
three
Coulson comes clean about the alien
markings based on the way that he
described the carvings he makes it sound
like a really unconscious thing like he
doesn't think about what the map is
supposed to look like it just comes out
that way so I'm thinking two
possibilities Inhumans or guardians of
the galaxy so I'll explain
Inhumans first the whole idea behind
terrigenesis
is that it unlocks something inside you
that's hidden or just strips away the
shell so Coulson's subconscious is
forcibly working its way to the surface
it could be an early stage of what
happens whenever you take in the
Terrigen mists not everyone survives
them ones that do survive become
Inhumans and get crazy powers it's like
a way of saying the Inhumans are trying
to assure in a brave new world not
everyone is meant to live in it like
Garrett for instance Coulson said you
thought Garrett was not meant to survive
that Kree formula marble is pretty
convoluted when it comes to who has the
rights to do what on TV and film it's
all different but I do believe they have
the rights to do the Inhumans if they
wanted to if that's what's going on the
map could just be a map to Attilan or it
could be a genetic map the other
possibility is that the carvings are a
literal map to some
from the guardians of the galaxy stories
like an outerspace story there is a link
between Korean and humans
so if it's like a Guardians tie-in then
it would be more creep than in humans
here's why I think this is less likely
though I don't think it's gonna be a
Guardians crossover James Gunn said the
guardians to was not gonna add any new
human characters and he kind of just
wanted them to exist off on their own
little corner of the Marvel Universe
media that the Guardian stuff just would
directly overlap with the other Marvel
movie stuff even if that's true I think
that the Ovilus part of the diviner or
whatever you want to call it now is
create an origin so there is a subtle
link to the guardians of the galaxy
universe in terms of the movie universe
that is number two goes down at
Hydra the stand up between rain and
Coulson was pretty funny
Coulson just not buying their
we all know that Mockingbird was gonna
be a double agent though so that reveal
wasn't as surprising the promos last
week pretty much spoiled all that that
Black Widow seemed that she got though
that was pretty badass Simmons of course
always hilarious in situations like that
I think it makes the action work that
much better I mean I don't like shield
when it takes itself too seriously it's
just a lot more fun to play those
Simmons reactions off the crazy
batchi villain and relight the actors
we're actually sitting right next to
each other in live-tweeting the episode
i always laugh a little whenever you see
villains and heroes on shows just
chilling out like pros in real life I
mean it's just a Hollywood thing but
it's funny when you see them behind the
scenes the rooftop jump was probably my
favorite stunt from the episode with the
Quinn ship reveal they keep giving
Simmons crazier and crazier stunts so
I'm interested to see if she and Fitz
get like a big shared action moment now
that they've been reunited and that was
big them actually being in the same room
together it ended up feeling like a bit
of a downer though I feel like it's
gonna take several episodes before Fitz
warms back up to her and my number one
moment
mockingbirds joins the team I don't know
how many episodes are on her contract
hopefully she'll be here through the
season 2 finale mixture I'm talking like
the back half episodes she did say that
there's a clause in her contract that
might allow her to cross over into the
movies I'm thinking Captain America 3 is
pretty likely candidate for that just
because a lot of shield characters
always end up at Captain America movies
it's a little too late for her to be in
Avengers 2 now that she's on the team
though I feel like she's gonna balance
out the main equation like may is the
Calvary she's a
but she's really cold so I feel like
Mockingbird is gonna get a lot of the
jokes that they can't give to me like
the badass female jokes sky isn't really
a badass even though she's very capable
she mostly gets the silly jokes like the
ones that hunter can't do speaking of
which I feel like we all kind of thought
that she was gonna be the crazy ex-wife
that hunter just would not shut up about
it just would have been too sweet if
it'd have been true which is why I was
so happy when they confirmed it it just
means that the team's gonna get to have
that much more fun gaming Hunter
admittedly douchebag just a bunch of
this season about it based on her
rapport with the team it feels like she
goes way way back with some of the
veteran members the reference to her
hair was a nod to Mockingbird in the
comics though being blonde also Adrianne
Palicki was a blonde on Friday night
light so you could take it either way
like as a week to the comics or to
Friday Night Lights I think it was more
of a comic book Easter Egg just as a
bonus I have to mention Skye's dad he's
a really big deal on the show but we're
just now getting to know him he is very
clearly affected by the obelisk
so I'm guessing he studied it for a long
time it just was changed physically
somehow we didn't see him transform or
anything in the episode but it did seem
like he has super strength Skye called
him a monster so I wouldn't be surprised
if he turns into a real monster by the
end of his arc I'm hoping he makes it
past the mid-season finale the Garrett
character actually lasted through a
whole season so now I'm kind of thinking
of him as the new Garrett Kraken is the
Macbeth but I feel like the tease at the
end of this episode was masters of evil
so I don't know who his characters gonna
end up being Skye's dad but that's what
I'm thinking right now it's just like a
version of masters of evil let me know
though what was your favorite moment and
what do you think is gonna happen what's
guys dad like is he actually gonna turn
into a monster at some point this season
so overall I gave the episode of solid
b-plus it really did feel like a short
movie like a very short Captain America
movie I totally loved the way they made
Adrianne Palicki character look like
Black Widow like they gave her that
Black Widow badass moment one of the
only things that really didn't like
about the episode was the Ward scene I
just I'm not digging Ward in that prison
I feel like he needs to get out and stop
acting like humble word and just be a
normal person I'm just getting a little
tired of hearing him say I'm never gonna
lie to you Skye the good thing about
that though is that they are letting him
out of the cage next week like in next
week's episode he's actually
come out of there and help them out
clearly the writers have a plan for his
character so I'm really interested to
see where they're gonna take him and
they're not just gonna like swing and
make too good everyone's not just gonna
totally forgive him he's gonna to redeem
himself somehow I'm guessing it's gonna
have something to do with defeating
Skye's dad and crackin
or neutralizing the Ovilus like they'll
have to throw himself on that spear
either way let me know if you've spotted
any of the really big Easter eggs from
the episode just leave them in the
comments Avengers age of Ultron trailer
next week so be sure to subscribe to get
that video that'll be like the first
thing I post Tuesday night just to
explain the footage we're gonna see
we'll probably see Ultron mark 1 we'll
probably see the final version you know
with the full-on voice parades marching
around destroying stuff we'll see all
the new suits Captain America has a new
suit Iron Man has a new suit they're
just variations on the ones they have
right now but they do look really cool
they did have that funny Avengers party
scene in the comic-con trailer I don't
expect them to repeat that I don't think
that's gonna be in the really the
important stuff is just kind of setting
up what the arc is gonna be you know
Tony Stark overwhelmed with work a bit
of a lazy person creates a robot to do
it for him robot those evil tries to
kill them all you know very simple story
the really interesting thing that Joss
Whedon is said about the movie is that
Captain America and Iron Man will
definitely not be friends in the movie
that's kind of his words he said they
definitely won't be friends it just
seems like more evidence that they're
setting up a Captain America 3 Civil War
storyline which is basically what
everyone has been saying I actually did
a video on that just a little while ago
so you can click to learn all about it
Tony Stark is totally gonna be Captain
America 3 so pretty much Civil War right
there and click here to get my agents of
shield episode 4 video thank you so much
for watching
so let's high five and I'll see you guys
tonight
you